kaum zu glauben himmel feinem sandstrand
und 20 grad mallorca lebt wieder auf und
ein stück male macht nun auch endlich
wieder auf es geht um den mega park ja
einige von ihnen werden eventuell sehr
lange darauf gewartet haben nun ist es
endlich wieder soweit nach zweieinhalb
jahren muss man sich auch mal vorstellen
corona bedingter durststrecke endlich
wieder menschen endlich wieder
strohhalme in st reagiert natürlich
foto
mein herz schlägt für den
begrabt mich doch in
a
sehr ich mich freue die im ganzen
menschen hier zu sehen dass sie auch
alle genauso wie wir darauf warten dass
der mega park endlich wieder aufmachen
kann ich freue mich ich hole mir auch
gleich mein erstes bier ab ich fühle
mich fantastisch nach zwei jahren pause
endlich wieder hier zu sein weil bei
alte haltestelle ist es einfach wahnsinn
[Musik]
sie sparen die heimat
das
naja
[Musik]
auf einer skala von eins bis zehn der
elf würde ich sagen das ding war zwei
jahre zu das wird höchste zeit dass er
wieder aufgeladen sind seit gestern da
bleiben bis zum samstag und getrunken
haben wir recht viel in
folge hat der erste hier heute
herangegangen ist gott sei dank nach
zwei jahren und ich denke wir werden bis
zum schluss hier bleiben
[Musik]
wir waren seit 10 uhr hier direkt zum
opening volle bude sonne scheint
tipptopp besser kann sich sein nicht
alte welt ist zurück ich bin hier heute
morgen rein gelaufen und es war wieder
so viele vor corona und das ist einfach
wunderbar paris
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so und wer war dann natürlich mittendrin
natürlich unser kollege manfred
sedlbauer ist mit nach halle gereist und
das sind jetzt hier seine eindrücke
hinter uns die leute im megapark nach
zweieinhalb jahren durststrecke dürfen
sie endlich wieder tanzen trinken und
grün was das zeug hält und es war heute
schon ganz klar komisch ganz ganz toll
zu sehen zwei stunden vor der eröffnung
waren die leute hier schon vor dem
megapark schlange gestanden und die
konnten es einfach nicht erwarten
endlich wieder drin einfach gas zu geben
und wir haben jetzt die möglichkeit mit
zwei sängerinnen zu sprechen die dort
heute schon aufgetreten sind wie wir
statt mal mit dir du was die erste die
nach zweieinhalb jahren durststrecke wir
haben es gesagt endlich wieder auf der
bühne stand was war das denn für ein
gefühl für dich endlich wieder auf der
bühne vor den ganzen feierwütigen
performance zu dürfen also ich war
allein gestern schon total wird ich habe
gedacht oh mein gott oh mein gott dann
will ich es heute morgen schon runter
gefahren für den mega park um das gefühl
eine aufziehende saugen von den leuten
von atmosphäre habe mich schon sehr gut
getan und dann die nervosität aber doch
wieder stärker und dann bin ich hoch und
anwalt wirklich steckt aber war halt
auch so doch mit meinen 19 mittlerweile
du wirst was ich brauche und es sind
sowieso immer sehr aufregend wie kommt
das von den leuten an und es galt flair
steht auch hier bei uns du warst die
zweite heute auf der bühne wie hast du
die menschen wie hast du die stimmung
wahrgenommen hatten die so ein bisschen
sehnsucht auch was vielleicht heute
sogar spezielle als vor krone es ist
natürlich ein ganz anderes gefühl weil
man nicht so genau weiß noch man traut
sich noch nicht so man ist noch ein
bisschen vorsichtig man sieht dass den
leuten auch in den gesichtern an die
sind alle noch ein bisschen
zurückhaltend aber ich glaube das wird
nach und nach kommen ich meine wir
hatten jetzt zwei jahre pause was will
mann was haben ein anderes erwarten hier
beide standen heute schon auf der bühne
und es war wirklich fantastisch die
leute haben euch ab gefeiert aber so
einst der größte highlight steht uns
heute abend ja noch bevor und zwar
mittels heute um 20.30 live auf der
bühne im megapark und meine kollegin
kyra ortmann dierte die gelegenheit vor
ein paar minuten mit ihm am flughafen zu
sprechen und da können wir jetzt mal
rein
auf mallorca zu sein der flug war wie
immer leicht verspätet aber die
verspätung nimmt man ja mittlerweile in
kaufmann ist ja froh wenn man überhaupt
über darf nach mallorca und ja heute ist
mein erster auftritt im megapark es war
ein letzten tagen sehr schlechtes wetter
und der krause bringt gutes wetter mit
und deshalb freue ich mich natürlich
ganz besonders wollte hier sein zu
dürfen für mich ist das im grunde so als
hätte ich zwei jahre lang meinem
wohnzimmer nicht betreten dürfen und
jetzt habe ich endlich wieder in meinem
wohnzimmer früher war das niveau kann es
mal ein wohnzimmer und viele viele jahre
bis 2015 seiten unserer partner
und jetzt geht's endlich wieder
[Musik]
ja mittel kaufen darf endlich wieder
zurück in sein wohnzimmer und wir haben
hier noch einen überraschungsgast bei
uns stehen marc terenzi pop legende ist
bei uns und hier noch ein feierwütige
erzähl mal du standest heute zwar noch
nicht in der auf der bühne stehst auch
heute nicht auf der bühne aber was
machst du hier am ball wenn ihr sowieso
ich meine zweite wohnsitz hier bin hier
fast jede woche entführte ganz denn sie
sind eine marke opening up
ich bin hier die ganze zeit aber ich bin
hier das pony krause der ganzen schub
ihr treffen heute von merck hatte es
zumeist schon zwei shows in mehr
passieren dass sandte genießen heute am
hallo herr an so das wetter ist wirklich
fantastisch das war die letzten tage auf
jeden fall noch nicht so aber mag sag
mal was machst du genau weil du wirst ja
nicht auf der bühne stehen und schlager
singen nein ich mach software mainstream
shows von last year is oder cup vier
verschiedene shows hier ähnlich aber
neuen special show aber nicht genau was
ich aber immer noch des mainstreams
sagen sie alle kennen aus der disco sind
alle xing aber nicht schlagartig mehr
zum mainstream ganz kurz noch sein
lieblingslied an stimmen für berlin für
deutschland
damit zurück nach berlin